quisiera comenzar preguntándole por qué
según este informe américa latina y el
caribe estarían presentando esta
tendencia no al crecimiento al contrario
de lo que está ocurriendo en otras
regiones del mundo
bueno yo creo que hay tres factores
básicos el primero evidentemente es el
incremento en el precio
mundial de los commodities las materias
primas está afectando la capacidad de
consumo la capacidad de inversión de los
países de la región el segundo aspecto
es que esto afecta sobre todo a las dos
economías más grandes de la región que
son brasil y méxico- que en donde la
perspectiva del banco mundial es a la
baja brasil este año crecerá cerca de
1.5 por ciento y para méxico la
estimación es de 1.7 por ciento esto
porque fundamentalmente además de la
parte de materias primas tiene un
componente industrial es decir hay una
desaceleración en la parte de
manufacturas que afecta a estas dos
grandes naciones y el tercer aspecto
pues básicamente es la inercia que tiene
la región en donde después de la
recuperación del 2020 lo que vemos es de
que los programas de reactivación
económica en la mayor parte de los
países pues han culminado y entonces se
ve una desaceleración en la capacidad de
la política fiscal para generar más
crecimiento josé luís cree usted que es
posible que las perspectivas de
crecimiento mundial continúen bajando
conforme avance la guerra en ucrania
y me parece que sí porque porque al
final del día las afectaciones que
estamos viendo son una afectación a la
cadena de suministros de materias primas
que vienen de la región europea 2 porque
hay una afectación también en la
logística internacional 3 porque esto se
asocia además a lo que está ocurriendo
él sobre todo en china en donde por el
problema de kobe 19 pues esta región
manufacturera e industrial está también
afectando el suministro de insumos
intermedios sobre todo los de alta
tecnología y en ese sentido me parece
que estos elementos junto con los
problemas de presión de inflación global
y el aumento en tasas de interés que se
está utilizando para controlarlo son los
que pueden en un momento dado afectar el
ritmo de crecimiento en particular para
la región hablemos ahora de otro
organismo la cepal dijo recientemente
que la pobreza en américa latina se va a
disparar por supuesto como consecuencia
de la guerra en ucrania porque un
conflicto que parecería tan lejano no
afectará tanto a esta región
bueno en esencia es por los problemas de
inflación que esto implica los
incrementos en tasas de interés también
afectarán la capacidad de inversión
las deudas tendrán un mayor costo de
financiamiento y esto en términos
generales pues lo que va a reflejar es
un aumento en el saldo social de pobreza
que reflejan los problemas de
crecimiento endógeno que tienen los
países de américa latina